we mustn't be afraid of asserting some
values and one of the things that the
Islamists who have been exposed in this
investigation
I think share is the is the knowledge
that if that they will have to cut off
their young from the wider society if
they are not going to join the wider
society that's why the effort is to
exhaust for mixing with other well you
say maybe they're not going to succeed
there are paths this country clearly
where they have been succeeding and it's
only because of a letter now everyone
agrees mayor's probably been a hoax that
this has actually come about most of
these schools it's remember we're going
on with this many important remember
we're going on with their business have
been Ofsted inspected and have been
found to be doing just fine job was
getting very good exam results yes any
but and some of them were even said to
be no teaching great inclusivity and all
that sort of thing it took this to
expose what was going on in some of
these schools and I think that's a very
good last words man and you're rather
conflating the the hoax letter with what
is subsequently emerged nothing has
subsequently emerged the Micra which
again supporters any kind of credence to
the idea of some Trojan horse Islamist
plot to the will.shaw
report has discovered a number of very
unsatisfactory features in a number of
schools but no evidence of a Trojan
horse
it says they the fake letter was a
Trojan horse letter the Trojan horse
does not exist no but what does exist is
the reality which Michael will Shores
report is exposed which is an attempt to
cut off Muslim children in parts of this
country from the rest of society and to
inculcate in them separatist values the
facts are the ones that have just been
exposed that is the fact that religions
and communities have strong values and
strong cultural a strong sense of their
own culture and base sometimes go too
far in trying to impose it on their own
children so as I say vigilance is what
it is needed and not panic well I agree
with that I just don't think we need to
take the Quakers down at the same time
we we need to look at the question of
moral of Objectivism and religions do
teach moral objectivism that the the
Christian religion does too and they
teach a particular set of values and
they try to
use the word advisedly inculcate those
values the Church of England rather less
perhaps they Catholic Church rather more
and Islam no doubt rather more I don't
know much about Jewish faith schools but
I believe they exist and I would imagine
whether there to celebrate and inculcate
Jewish values I don't think taxpayers
should be paying for those things and so
I don't think this is a red herring and
I did I think Michael Gove does need to
sort out in his own mind whether he
thinks that a school should teach people
what to believe one of the ways in which
government is going to try to respond to
this and has already said they want to
respond to this is to emphasize and
strengthen the teaching of British
values in school I think the exact
wording was it was that schools are
gonna have to actively promote British
value as opposed to just generally
respect them I think is the difference
that it's a part of Education oh this is
nonsense and it's so unbrace the first
British value that I would want to lay
down with would be that we do not teach
British values try to inculcate British
values in schools how do you define
British values this is a very diverse I
mean yeah thanks I Matthew that's sort
of easy for you to say they're easy for
me to say maybe that a young boy or girl
growing up in parts of Birmingham today
may very well need to have some idea of
British values I think history I mean
I'm loath to use history as some kind of
you know indoctrination tool but I think
that at the very least one ought to
start by recognizing a lot of Muslims
came to this country precisely to flee
the kind of totalitarian Islam which is
now apparently being inculcated in some
parts of this country through the school
system I think it would be the greatest
tragedy imaginable if the thing they
tried to flee was then prevalent in
parts of this country I think that one
of the solutions to this is to explain
better how it is at this country how
this culture got to where we are now if
you pretend that we got here by a form
of gravity or inevitability or that all
other countries pretty much agree with
us you miss out on a very very important
chunk of this discussion things are best
taught by example and children are best
taught by seeing the Britain that
they're in and the world
around them and seeing how it works and
understanding which you learn more by
osmosis I think than by instruction wide
it works the moment you've set children
down in a classroom and try to hammer
into them what you call British values a
you'll encourage resistance amongst the
children and be you you will give the
impression but there's some sort of
attempt by the state to indoctrinate now
we're very against Islam indoctrinating
we mustn't respond by counter
indoctrinated